- He was a popular American author.
- He wrote the book Think and Grow Rich.
- He's Napoleon Hill and here
are his top ten rules for
success.
(wooshing noise)
- A definite purpose must
be accompanied by a definite
plan for detainment, followed
by appropriate action,
now you have to have a
purpose, you have to have a
plan, and you have to start
putting that plan into action.
And ladies and gentlemen,
it's not too important that
your plan be sound.
It is in fact, it's not too
important because if you find
that you've adopted a plan
that is not sound, it's
not working you can always change.
You can modify your plan,
but it is very important that
you be definite about what
it is you're going after,
what your purpose is, that
must be very definite.
Learn to adjust yourself
to other people's state of
mind and difficulties so
as to get along peacefully
with them and to refrain
from taking notice of trivial
circumstances in your
relations with other people by
refusing to allow them
to become controversial
incidents.
Great people always avoid
small incidents of controversy
when possible.
If you want the mind to
pick up an idea, and to form
a habit so that the mind
will automatically act upon
that idea you've got to
tell the mind what you want
over and over and over again.
No end to it.
When Mr. Coue came over
here some years ago with his
famous formula, day by day
in every way I'm getting
better and better, he
cured thousands of people
but a very great number
than that he didn't cure.
And I wonder if you would know why?
(audience murmuring)
There was no desire, there
was no feeling put into that
statement, you might as
well just blow into the wind
as to make a statement to
let you put some feeling
back of it, unless you believe it.
Well you need a pocket sized
notebook, all something
on the order of this one
here, looseleaf at that.
And on the page one write
down a clear description of
your major desire in life.
The one circumstance or
position or thing which you
will be willing to accept
as your idea of success.
And remember before you
begin writing that your only
limitations are those that
you set up in your own
mind or permit others to set up for you.
And two, on page two of
your notebook, write down a
clear statement of precisely
what you intend to give
in return for that which you
desire from life and then
start in right where you
stand now to begin giving and
three, memorize both of your
statements, what you desire
and what you intend to
give in return for it.
And repeat them at least a
dozen times daily and always
end your statements with
this expression of gratitude
for the blessings with which
you were gifted at birth.
Any dominating desire,
plan, or purpose which is
backed by that state of mind
known as faith, is taken
over by the subconscious
section of the mind and acted
upon immediately.
I don't know for sure ladies
and gentlemen, but I suspect
that there's a relatively
small number of people
in the world at any one
time who understand the
principle of faith, who
really understand it and know
how to apply it.
And even if you do understand
it, if you don't back
it up with action and make
it a part of your habit life
you might just as well
not understand it because
faith without deeds is dead.
Faith without action is
dead, faith without absolute
positive belief is dead.
I don't know how you're
going to get any results
through believing unless
you put some action back of
that belief.
And incidentally, if you tell
your mind often enough that
you have faith in anything,
the time will come when your
subconscious mind will
accept that, even if you tell
your mind often enough that
you have faith in yourself.
Have you ever thought about
nice thing would be if
you had such complete faith
in yourself that you wouldn't
hesitate to undertake anything
you wanted to do in life?
Had you ever thought about that?
What a benefit that would be to you?
Your personality determines
whether people are attracted
to you or shy away from
you, it is the show in which
you display your character
to the world and it is
the one thing which
distinguishes you from all other
human beings.
It is your trademark by which
people recognize you and
it is the thing which determines
your success or failure
in selling yourself through life.
Therefore, you should see your
personality just as others
see it, so you may improve it
where it needs improvement.
If you would sit down and put
an hour by hour of account
of the actual work that
you put in each day for one
week and then an hour by
hour account of the time
that you waste that you
could devote to anything you
want to do badly enough.
You're going to get one of
the shocks of your life.
We're not efficient, you know
we have about eight hours
to sleep, about eight
hours to earn a living, and
have eight hours of free
time that you can do anything
that you want to with here in
this country where we live.
And then definiteness as a
purpose makes one more alert
in recognizing opportunities
related to the object of
one's major purpose and it
inspires the courage to embrace
and act upon those opportunities.
Now, we all see opportunities
almost everyday of our lives
which if we embrace them and
acted upon them could benefit
us, but there's something in us that we
call procrastination, we
just don't have the will,
the alertness, the determination
to embrace opportunities
when they come along.
But if you condition your mind
with this philosophy, you'll
not only embrace opportunities,
but you'll do something
better, what could you
do better than embrace
an opportunity?
(audience speaking)
Make the opportunity, that's the idea.
Success is something which
has to be planned and
success is something which
has to be earned in advance.
True, there is such a thing
as luck, but just remember
luck is something that you
can create for yourself
if you know the rules and
follow them just as I give
them to you.
Remember too that success
in the higher brackets of
achievement is something
that can be had only by
taking others along with you
and the best definition of
success which I know is this,
success is the knowledge
with which to get whatever
you want from life without
violating the rights of
others and by helping others
to acquire it.
The very minute that you
decide upon something, you
know that's what you want,
you know you're going to do
it, all of these negative
that have been bothering
you, they pick up their
baggage and get out.
They just move out, they
can't live in a positive
mind, can you imagine a
negative frame of mind and a
positive frame of mind
occupying the same space at
the same time?
Could you imagine that?
No, you can't cuz it can't
be done and did you know that
the slightest bit of a
negative and mental attitude is
sufficient to destroy the power of prayer?
Did you know that the slightest
bit of a negative mental
attitude is sufficient to
destroy your plan, whatever
it is you're doing?
Carrying out your definiteness of purpose?
You have to move with
courage, with faith, with
determination in connection
with carrying out your
definiteness of purpose.
Whatever the mind can
conceive and believe, the
mind can achieve.
Isn't that a profound statement?
You will notice that it
says nothing about the need
for education, but simply
that whatever your mind can
conceive and believe
your mind can achieve.
Now if you want evidence
that the mind can achieve
whatever the mind can
conceive without the benefit
of formal education, you'll
have to remember that
Thomas A. Edison conceived
the idea of becoming an
inventor and lived to
become the world's greatest
scientist in the field
of invention, with only
three months of common school education.
- Thank you so much for
watching, I made this video
because Business asked
me to, so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Napoleon Hill's top
ten rules you loved the most,
leave it in the comments.
We're going to join in the
discussion, thank you so much
for watching, continue to
believe and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing noise)